on m'accuse d'être un manipulateur
contrairement aux êtres humains ce que
je vais essayer de contrôler maintenant
est très facile à manipuler
on remonte gamme
vous pensez qu'ils avaient disparu
non on entend des cavaliers vous
récolterez ce que vous avez sonné et
vous serez les premiers à tenir
il maître de l'illusion dans un tour de
magie planétaire tout le monde sort de
scène va sauter d'un toit à new york
human et on a atterri en chine c'est
possible kaka a fait plus fort que nous
au quai sais pas comment vous êtes tombé
dans un piège c'est la clé pour accéder
à tous les systèmes informatiques
humaine je veux que vous la voyez pour
moi pour mes goûts
je peux le faire tout seul
avec ce numéro on va rentrer dans
l'histoire
merci de votre accueil
il n'ya pas longtemps on s'est fait
piéger
la réalité est toujours plus compliqué
qu'il n'y paraît
star
cette semaine
m
massa
record aussi chaud
il combine affichage
alors là
à